obviously got a lot more gray in the
beard than i did a few years ago
so i i know that the
football mortality catches up to
everybody
and you never want to lose
a season especially when you feel
felt great you know starting the season
not about our prospects but uh
you know we're gonna battle the next
next five weeks and put ourselves in a
position to
to be in the conversation and hopefully
it'll be enough and like i've always
said you just gotta get in
that's aaron rodgers after the packers
lost on sunday night to the vikings 24
to 17. first of all i don't see any gray
in the beard so maybe he's using some
product i i mean yeah i wouldn't think
he has to use product yeah he can't be
that gray at this point but second of
all
as you watch him deliver those words
i feel like there's so much more going
on
behind his face like you can kind of see
it in his eyes like oh there's so much
more i want to say yeah there's so much
more i want to say and i'm only going to
say so much and i think he's very smart
when it comes to choosing his words in
an effort to send a message that can be
plausibly denied if anyone says hey what
you're saying is you need a new coach
because your football mortality is
starting to play out and you only have
one super bowl championship and
and he's being measured maybe with a new
coach you would have another super bowl
championship before we can actually see
the gray in the beard yeah well i mean i
you know he can't be happy i do think
even i watched mike mccarthy on his
post-game press conference he looked a
little you know out on his feet like a
little bit in disbelief and shocked that
oh my gosh we're sitting here at four
six and one i never thought this was
going to happen it's not a good look for
the green bay packers whether it's mike
mccarthy in game management situations
right not asking for a measurement at
the end of the game then having to take
a timeout and then taking the time out
and then running the ball up the middle
for a no no gain proposition there on
fourth down but it just doesn't look
good either side of the ball right now i
still felt like they were going to have
a chance to win it or at least tie it
all the way up until yeah that's what we
got
throw behind stefan diggs that could
have gone very badly for the vikings as
minnesota was trying to kill the clock
it's that and that's the moment when
the vikings finally could exhale but but
yeah there's been this anticipation with
the packers all year long that
something's going to come that's what he
said 10 days ago aaron rodgers waiting
for that galvanizing moment right now
that moment was taken out of his hands
when his coach decided to punt on fourth
and short and i think that's going to be
the thing that ultimately pushes mark
murphy the ceo of the team toward
changing coaches that's going to be the
one thing that never goes away this year
yeah
his hands again there lad the end last
night throw the ball in fourth and one
yeah
it's aaron rodgers yeah you know it's
it's uh the galvanizing moment yeah
aaron rodgers trying to be nice and by
basically saying you know the team's
waiting for me to do something
spectacular that we can all just rally
around i mean that's what and my coach
needs to let me do something spectacular
that's the problem a little bit
let me ask you this question i'm capable
we we we're going to talk about the
vikings at some point because obviously
they deserve to be celebrated for
winning the game and getting to see no
you want to celebrate them i i wanted to
be right i picked the pictures yesterday
i really paid full price i don't believe
it i'm throwing a challenge like mike
florio came into the workplace
with a nice uh vikings like what was it
what do you call it it's the salute to
service it's great it's great great
sweatshirt makes me feel tough but i
don't think you bought it at once i've
got listen i've got i'm i've i'm going
to show you during the break i've got
the amazon receipt right here
media guy send me sweatshirt or i i paid
here here's what happened my son wanted
one yes so i ordered it for him and when
it came it's like this thing's really
nice so i got one for myself right full
price paid so don't start down that path
okay i'll show you okay all right um now
what are we talking about oh
that stats that stats had
stats you go ahead and you ask him the
question he's got me all flummoxed down
after you got me getting free stuff
how is it chris that when the packers
win right it's all because of aaron
rodgers but when they lose all the blame
goes to mike mccarthy well uh you listen
i i don't know what to say there because
uh that's usually the truth of the
matter i think that's really what my
answer would be for you to uh stats you
know again not that um
this offense that they run in green bay
you've heard me say this nine million
times now it is so basic there's no
answers it's it's the type of offense
where i would say new england runs these
plays the first three to four days of
training camp as just like base let's
get our feet wet and let's get practice
started and then they don't even revisit
some of these plays as the year goes on
that's how elementary it is at times now
yes we give him the credit when they win
because think about when they win i mean
it's oh he's bringing them back from a
20 to nothing comeback on one leg so
whoa he made amazing throws on one leg
made him made amazing plays with his
feet whatever it may be
now hey listen could he have played a
little bit better last night but sure
and i'm sure there's things that i see
on film but you you watched it you
watched the game stats i mean
i don't think there's people flying open
across the field he's got no pass
protection and a lot of big moments and
the run game yeah okay look we make a
big deal when they run for 70 yards
that's that's what it's turned into so i
don't know if that answers your question
at all but i just think that's really
the reality of the green bay packers
right now that's why we're having this
conversation about mike mccarthy from
time to time when we try to figure out
what's wrong with the packers i i do at
least entertain the possibility that
some of it is on aaron rodgers that just
because he can throw those passes from
time to time that are just amazing the
accuracy while he's falling backward he
throws it 40 yards down the field it
drops right in because he's capable of
doing that we lose sight of the fact
that maybe he doesn't bring to the table
some of the skills that the other
quarterbacks have from the standpoint of
the intangibles the leadership inspiring
guys to do their jobs so you you're not
frustrated with a guy during a game that
there's an accountability there like a
peyton manning or tom brady would have
where guys don't make mistakes and and i
don't know i mean it's impossible to
pierce behind that veil and find out
what guys really think of aaron rodgers
but remember a couple of years ago when
they were struggling there was an item
from tyler dunn i think of bleacher
report delving into this question of
what kind of a leader aaron rodgers is
and once they ran the table that year
it's like that narrative went away for
good right i think that's still a fair
question to ask because at some point it
it can't be
it's not fair to mike mccarthy to say
if they win it's because aaron rodgers
overcame mike mccarthy and if they lose
it's because mark mccarthy overcame
aaron rodgers at some point we have to
look at aaron rodgers and say you're the
guy who's been the quarterback all along
but there's been plenty of quarterbacks
over the years that have had to deal
with substandard coaches and
sub-standard performing uh surrounding
cast and they've still gotten it done
well yeah like who tell me i mean
that's just a broad bullcrap statement
no it's not not it is it's just right
there's been guys out there that have
done it before i mean yep okay i'll take
your word for it no you're see what
you're talking about is the culture set
by the head coach that's where i would
push back on you you know yeah brady's a
great leader because he's been you know
groomed into that there in new england
drew brees with sean payton he's got a
guy on his shoulder you know the devil
and the angel all the time tell him to
be better that's that's where i think
they missed russell wilson has performed
really well in seattle and with daryl
beville is the offensive shirt i mean
there's an example of a guy that's
overcome the coaching deficiencies
around him i get you and i wouldn't even
say i i would have loved to assume those
but in those years too i would push back
and go in some of those years where
you're talking about it they still had
like one of the best running offenses in
football with marshawn lynch and the
things they were doing they used it when
they needed it that's just that's all
i'm saying i'm you know but but i mean
your point's just i know he's not the
only guy ever stats has helped me out
here and good luck his first few years
in indianapolis with chuck pagano and
ryan griggs oh so now andrew luck so now
andrew luck's good look at this so
andrew wait a minute now you're moving
the goalposts on me yeah right you can't
win the playoff games and all this but
now he's carrying the team it's well
yeah okay rogers brings his team to the
playoffs under the same circumstances
too why don't you if
i just don't like that argument because
if drew brees was so great how come he's
only been to the playoffs twice in the
last nine years because the defense has
been oh but that doesn't see aaron
rodgers doesn't get that talk it's been
worse than horrible he doesn't have the
run game drew brees does he doesn't have
the coach he does he doesn't have the
o-line he has he doesn't have a receiver
like michael thomas he's had people like
james jones who can't be on a football
team and catch a pass anywhere else and
then he comes back to green bay and he
leads the league in touchdown passes
here's here's the reality it doesn't
matter because
the only change
the only change that can be made as a
practical matter is a new coach i think
you're not going to get rid of aaron
rodgers so it's going to be a new coach
i'd be shocked if it isn't in green bay
and i think the fans and the the owners
right yes the shareholders will rise up
and uh and and seek the ouster i think
of mark murphy if they don't change
coaches i i think so i mean i just i
think it's gotten to the point where
it's it's fairly obvious i i mean at
least in my eyes just with some of the
game planning plays you see how much
work it is you see that when they do
make plays it's a lot of times something
spectacular from aaron rodgers you know
the year the difference between this
year i think in years past right the
offensive line is not as good as far as
past protecting that always gave rogers
the chance to dance around and then make
the magic and go into the zone like you
talk about that we see him do and that's
that made them uh have the ability to
overcome these situations we're seeing
them in uh this year but the o line's
not the same this year and randall
cobb's not healthy and he's got young
receivers around him and they got rid of
jordan
sure right so all those things have led
into where we are now uh and i just
think that's that's really the big issue
with the green bay packers and they're
in big trouble all right i have reserved
we didn't even 60 to 90 seconds for the
vikings here well i just want to
kirk cousins in prime time three
touchdowns he went oh my gosh the lights
are on and it's night time let me go on
fire you know what my lights are always
on in the dome they are always out of
the door but hey you know what good kirk
congratulations you you you have yeah no
no i picked the packers to win i wanted
to be right it's like reverse psychosis
it's not reverse psycho you're like you
do it because you're like i might be
right i'm wrong vince i feel good
because my team still won i was
convinced that the packers would win the
game and the vikings were going to tail
spin out of the postseason because
they've got at the patriots and at
seattle coming up and you know it's no
lock the vikings make it to the playoffs
that they may find themselves because i
think they will lose each of the next
two games at new england at seattle and
that'll drop to six six and one they win
the final three against the dolphins the
lions and the bears they likely get in
at nine six and one that's where that
tie comes in handy it allows you to get
ahead of anyone who's nine and seven
right but they're gonna have to win the
last three they're gonna have to pull
that inside straight week 15 weeks 16
week 17 or they ain't getting in because
i uh hey hey kirk proved me wrong again
buddy you go to new england and win i
i'll take back all the all the shoes
that were thrown at the tv with all the
dumb things that he did throughout the
year and he didn't do any last night
there wasn't one of those moments where
you're like oh god what they're paying
this guy 28 million he was good for most
of the game although early on early on
he did badly miss stefan diggs prompting
chris collinsworth to say that is not
professional football that's the most
damning indictment you can ever have
right of a professional quarterback
saying that is just not professional
football later in the game though he was
very accurate he was making great throws
adam thielen and stefan diggs were
making great catches kyle rudolph they
incorporated him into the offense more
you know my theory on this has been that
offensive coordinator john d filippo is
so intent on becoming a head coach next
year he is forcing the vikings into
situations that showcase his ability
instead of doing the meat and potatoes
thing i'm with driving
down the front
of the tight end and running the ball
yeah i'm with you i think a lot of
offensive coordinators fall into that
they go if my quarterback's numbers are
good i'll be called a horse a
quarterback whisperer right and i i
don't even know what i almost said you
almost said horse whisper horse first i
think yeah i think you're right no but
i'll become a quarterback whisperer and
then i become a head coach and yes you
know what's funny is when he was a
successful play caller for the cleveland
browns you know who his head coach was
mike pettin who was famous for going run
the ball running the ball and now yes it
sounds like mike zimmer's had to get in
his ear and when they run the ball you
see just some of the throws over the
middle like you're talking about to the
tight ends the digs over the middle the
feelings over the middle it becomes wide
open offense becomes easier and i don't
like this
head coach who only takes care of the
side of the ball that allowed him to
become a head coach i think mike zimmer
is experienced enough and he's smart
enough and he's innovative enough if he
lets himself be that way to be involved
often surely and it sounds like he's
starting to get there because he's
sending the clear message to john d
filippo run the ball run the ball run
the ball right and
uh i said but i really i always have
misgivings about the offensive
coordinator who is thinking about his
next job and is doing everything he can
to set himself up for that next job
because it has felt that way too many
times this year that's exactly what d
philippe is doing yep hi i'm mike tarico
and thanks for watching make sure to hit
subscribe for the latest news and
highlights from nbc sports